sprengstoff alarm in berlin friedlich
sein
eigentlich wollten polizeibeamte am
dienstagabend eine wohnung in der
bertinistraße wegen massive marihuana
und haschisch geruchs überprüfen mit
richterlichem beschluss öffneten sie
diese und fanden darin eine kleine
hanfplantage
doch dann entdeckten beamte auch große
mengen exklusiver stoffe in der wohnung
ein großeinsatz der polizei feuerwehr
und notarzt wagen lief an
spezialkräfte des lka in schärfer und
sprengstoffexperten rückten an
über sechs stunden lang sicherten sie
immer mehr material welches noch vor ort
kontrolliert abgebrannt werden musste
ein löschfahrzeug sicherte den
einsatzort nach bild informationen
handelte sich um stoffe die auch
terroristen sprengstoffgürtel verwenden
warum der mieter diese lagert muss nun
das lka klären
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren